what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and happy New Year welcome to 2023 where
the Multiverse Saga for Marvel Studios
is about to get very very interesting
and it looks like Marvel fans are going
to be extremely happy with how some
things are panning out for Avengers the
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars in
fact today we're going to be talking
about some major cameos in the secret
Wars film and some plot details that
have recently been revealed details
about both the Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars but most importantly who is going
to show up and have a scene together in
a brand new exciting report we've heard
that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man are going to get a
scene together where they fight
alongside each other and this is kind of
wish fulfillment for Kevin feige but
also part of a big plan that he has for
Secret Wars so let's break down this
plan talk about the scene with Hugh
Jackman and Toby Maguire and talk about
these plot details for Secret Wars and
the Kang Dynasty now first things first
what you need to know about the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars is it's
basically a two-part movie it's pretty
much going to be just like Avengers
Infinity war and Avengers end game the
only difference is and it's a great
difference is that we don't have to wait
a full year to see Secret Wars after the
King Dynasty which is great because it
looks like there is going to be a lot of
things in secret Wars that fans are just
absolutely going to lose their minds
about starting with a scene with Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine and Toby Maguire's
Spider-Man now if you started to love
Marvel way back in 2000 with the release
of the first X-Men movie there's going
to be so much that you love about Secret
Wars mainly because many of the actors
and characters from those old movies
that exist outside of the MCU are most
likely going to show up in secret Wars
today we have a report from my time to
shine hello an Insider account that is
very accurate with a lot of leaks that
she scoops and recently she tweeted yes
Toby Maguire and Hugh Jackman will meet
and fight alongside each other in secret
Wars again every Marvel's Fan's dream
come true the 2K characters and actors
that really started off Marvel on the
big screen that is Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine debuted in the first X-Men
film in the year 2000 Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man debuted two years after in
2002. so these two are basically the
pioneers of new age Marvel on the big
screen and it's fantastic that the two
of them are going to meet because that
just makes perfect sense now as far as
how they are going to meet we have those
details we've known them for quite a bit
but as far as how the actual timeline is
going to go for the Kang Dynasty in
secret Wars we have a little bit of a
better understanding now of course we
know that Kang is going to threaten the
entire Multiverse he is trying to
conquer it he's trying to conquer every
single Universe out there and the big
problem is and the story from Secret
Wars and the comics is that we are going
to experience incursions universes
colliding into each other and as John
krasinski's Mr Fantastic explained in
the Multiverse of Madness this isn't
good this can cause one or both of the
universes to be completely destroyed so
in a way there are kind of two threats
that the Avengers and the rest of the
heroes are going to have to deal with
both are caused by Kang but one is Kang
himself and the other is the Multiverse
simply falling apart and incursions
happening which could result in the
death of the entire Multiverse and this
is what they explained to us very well
in Loki not only did Miss minutes kind
of tell us the whole entire story about
the big multiversal war but then he who
remains told us a somewhat different
story but the reality is both of the
stories combined are true minus the
timekeepers the Multiverse a war did
cause a bunch of incursions which almost
did cause the collapse of the entire
Multiverse but at the same time Kang
variants were battling each other and
fighting for control over the entire
Multiverse but when are we going to see
all of this happen in the MCU in Phase 5
and phase six exactly well according to
another report from the account my time
to shine hello she says this is how they
plan to make secret Wars work without
making it a four hour movie side note I
would love for it to be a four hour
movie but you can't always get what you
want but finishing her report she stated
this is how they plan to make secret
Wars work without making it a four hour
movie Kang Dynasty will have the new
Avengers as the leads while Secret Wars
will mostly be from the point of view
and will focus on the heroes from the
other universes so the King Dynasty sets
up the new Avengers team but Secret Wars
is going to be about the multiversal
team and this is extremely cool because
it offers a very different storytelling
perspective than anything that we've
really experienced in the MCU so far we
got a tiny taste of it with Multiverse
of Madness but Secret Wars is really
going to dive into different story lines
in different universes all happening at
the same time and we're going to see all
of these teams have to communicate with
each other and have to work together so
a multiversal team will be formed and
also at the same time some of these
universes are going to be colliding with
each other so some of these teams are
indeed going to end up in the same
universe as each other whether that's by
choice or not due to an incursion and
here's something to think think about
out of all of the other universes out
there that we're going to come in
contact with that our Avengers team is
going to come in contact with we're
probably not the most advanced Universe
in fact in Multiverse of Madness their
Universe their Earth Earth 838 did seem
to be more advanced than ours especially
if you take a look at how Mr Fantastic
entered the room
smartest man alive
Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
hello Stephen and they actually did know
about incursions something in our
universe or at least the protector of
reality of our universe Doctor Strange
didn't know about and I doubt that this
is the most technologically advanced
Universe out there in fact I'm assuming
that there's another Universe out there
that has figured out how to
scientifically travel the Multiverse
however they don't do it because they
don't want to risk incursions and I'm
also willing to bet that it's a variant
of Reed Richards that has figured this
out or maybe even our read Richards is
going to be the one to figure out how to
Multiverse jump but the great part of
this is it will ultimately lead to
scenes between many Heroes that we know
and love interacting with each other
like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and Toby
Maguire Spider-Man and not only are
these characters going to meet each
other but they're going to fight
alongside each other fighting against
Kang and his army which I'm assuming
based off of some rumors that we've
heard is also going to consist of some
variants of characters who are maybe not
so good in some other universes but are
bad and fighting alongside Kang so truly
as I've been saying anything is possible
in this movie Wolverine and Spider-Man
are going to interact but there's going
to be other characters as well think
about Ben Affleck's Daredevil
interacting with our Daredevil Charlie
Cox think about Patrick Stewart's
Professor Xavier interacting with Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool something that I
think Ryan Reynolds has been wanting to
do for a very long time and then of
course let's not forget about some
variants of some dead Avengers they
could also be coming back as well Robert
Downey Jr could come back as a variant
of Iron Man or he could even play
another character perhaps in Another
Universe he goes on to become Captain
America his father was directly involved
with the Captain America project so who
knows also Black Widow has been rumored
to be coming back in secret Wars as well
this just makes sense and it's probably
going to be very emotional for some of
our heroes to interact with these
variants of characters that they've lost
think about Professor Hulk seeing
Natasha in Another Universe think about
Tom Holland's Spider-Man scene Tony
Stark From Another Universe that's going
to be very emotional but the cool part
is is basically if you can think about
it it's possible but I'm sure it's not
all all going to be good I'm sure some
of our heroes are actually going to
clash heads and possibly fight with
other Heroes because I'm sure each
different universe and all of its
variants aren't exactly going to agree
on a plan right away I'm sure there's
going to be some type of a council where
they all talk about what they agree
would be the best plan and I'm sure it's
not all going to be agreed upon right
away so seeing a little friendly fight
but also not so friendly fight between
the variants who are all trying to work
together is also possible and something
I hope we do see no deaths or anything
like that but kind of like how Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man had a little fight
with Tobey Maguire Spider-Man that but
hopefully times 10 because that was way
too short but the timeline for when to
expect all of this is going to be in
secret Wars so don't expect much from
the Kang Dynasty as far as Multiverse
jumping is concerned that movie is
mainly going to be about the new
Avengers but then in secret Wars that's
when the multiversal jumping is really
going to happen and the big multiversal
team of Heroes is going to come together
to fight Kang so let us know what you
think about this down below also let us
know who you would love to see interact
with each other whether that's
characters from the fox X-Men universe
or the MCU or both let us know your
thoughts down below don't forget to give
the video a like And subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof